hello and welcome to this video playing
cross see what he plays against the
eloquently 493 now that's a dislike of
course let's see
takes on d6 okay I cannot play something
fancy there I am manager suit your suit
just recapture likey fix up so this what
I was talking about so where do I go
threaten English step 3
[Music]
imaging the pawn structure RT can go b3
or something something simple
okay so do I want to compete for me a
dream no why not if he plays if he
advances like these seven books okay
yeah I think I'm happy to trade this so
that I have better challenges to
pressurize the default pawn so
especially belongs here and now I try to
get something going against the porn
gram if I call 85 he might go B sighs
huh possible but okay let's just do what
I wanted to do anyway put the night over
to e6 and see what happens let's stop
that
no 25 of them nope doesn't do it
what if one would have blundered poor
and I think just put it here hmm
it doesn't look so bad and I've got some
play against the pawn dev told you see
cavity for here Knight b3 I can even
consider I can actually take b5 okay so
probably probably people take on c6
first no okay so one let's say I take it
what is the big point there I don't see
it I think I just wind is born I can't
even play before here and then knight c6
or queen F is Queen at - ow good somehow
something weird
oh this one okay
yeah that's possible
the 7s not a porn that I can afford to
lose that looks a bit wrong but so came
I saw no way to cover this Evan
okay so reasonably active here against
this Paul just this he might have should
chief while these kind of things would
love to prevent that somehow I also
think about look a for here put more
pressure
let's do it
and d5 is still also we can look see
form doesn't doesn't really do much
I had freaking bring the second rook
okay I want to have 97 f5 I not serious
for him to do something I mean there the
night on these three years kind of stuck
them as default always under pressure
okay so he wants to play some stuff to
be fine
however it was unprotected so if I take
here
am I not winning stuff
and no bees have not slangs okay but I
have to have to apply something now
didn't think about this
waita said well okay I can take twice
them now this is probably easier to do
like this now take here Jam probably not
much not much I worry little bit behind
on the clock here it's probably just a
draw
I don't see anything great at least
still try to take here take the pawn on
in okay that can be a quick bond I am
Not sure that you can afford to just
take that everything on Visa Check
yes check that will promote with a big
check
white resides oh okay how much time I
was tough I mean what a typical Ella
cons game somehow I had this pressure
against deform and yeah looked
interesting computer likes my chair I
don't think this is all that much the
bishop and doesn't feel very relevant
maybe I could have played this
differently
[Music]
Mattia must be okay
Jan maybe somewhere here you can do it
more precisely Queen d7 is given by the
engine I simply didn't really have a
queen d5 on the right now it's a bit
embarrassing I mean I'm still okay with
probably equal to share now I could take
we should take some shoot I can just
take you to my daughter I just take the
bishop on e2 I was kind of wondering why
study would possible yeah I did not
really anticipate can just take the
bishop tweak this is not exactly
difficult I mean this this doesn't do
much I just have to form I keep keep
making life difficult for me really yeah
probably not much is going on but yeah
it got got tricky I can take p7 but
that's not so easy to have to play in a
in a situation like this and that does
it the solution
I will be a does the thing that's always
the street check check out so if I T
okay he's got cash checks ma'am
and that's that doesn't work
chan chan yeah yeah tough game thanks
for watching